[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt eine kleine ich würde
schon sagen mit geburtstagstorte und
zwar habe ich einen ekel gebacken und
der igel der hat im innern einen
haselnuss teig mit nougat ist richtig
lecker das ganze habe ich jetzt diesmal
komplett ohne fondant gemacht also für
alle die von doch nicht mögen
die degut die es aus modelle schokolade
gemacht und der igel ist auch wirklich
super schnell gemacht also ganz einfach
wenn ihr ein paar einfache tricks
beachtet
ich habe einen blechkuchen gebacken und
daraus dann einfach kuchen ausgestochen
und zusammengesetzt und ich finde das
echt ne süße geburtstags idee fünf
kindergeburtstag
wobei ich mich als erwachsene auch
darüber freuen werde und ich zeige euch
jetzt zuerst einmal die zutaten für den
rührteig denn damit geht es los
für den teig verwende ich feiere 200
gramm zucker eine prise salz vanille
extrakt 250 gramm haselnüsse 200 gramm
nuss nugat 250 gramm sonnenblumenöl und
50 milliliter milch 200 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel backpulver und 100 gramm
schokolade streife es gebe jetzt zuerst
die eier interieur schüsse da kommen das
salz und zucker mit dazu etwas vanille
extrakt immer gut durchschütteln damit
sich das vanillemark gut verteilt und
jetzt werden hier die zutaten in etwa
fünf minuten ganz cremig verrührt und
ich kann in der zwischenzeit die
haselnuss nehmen fein reiben und dann in
einer pfanne ohne fett rösten
das mache ich so immer ganz gerne weil
die haselnuss es so noch ihr volles
aroma haben und was ich auch noch machen
kann ist dass nougat schmelzen im
wasserbad
[Musik]
ist die amas schön cremig und die
haselnüsse habe ich jetzt vom herd
genommen und zwar dann wenn sie lecker
duften aber nicht verbrennen lassen
ich geh jetzt hier milch dazu ihr könnt
auch strudel nehmen ihr könnt auch
haselnuss likör nehmen aber wenn kinder
mit essen würde ich denn wir klassen auf
jeden fall dann das öl rein und jetzt
bei langsamer stufe rühren langsam
demokrat dazu
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier noch die restlichen
zutaten rein die schokostreusel und da
kommt der schokostreusel oder raspeln
nehmen
mehl und backpulver und natürlich die
gemahlin haselnüsse und bin ich den teig
mahl zubereitet da ist einfach
gigantisch riecht lecker schmeckt lecker
sofa saftig und muss ich jetzt einfach
nur noch ganz kurz unterrühren
[Musik]
und ich mag den teig jetzt auf einem
backblech
so kann ich nämlich die gesamte
teilmenge einmal komplett backen
ihr könnt natürlich auch wenn ihr
möchtet einfachrunde backformen nehmen
kleinere mit zb 14 bis 16 cm durchmesser
und ganz viele runde backen und
mischtechnik schneiden aber so hat man
einfach den vorteil alles auf einmal
backen zu können
[Musik]
der kuchen ist jetzt gebacken und ich
lasse ihn abkühlen und jetzt kann ich
aber in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
creme zu bereiten
ich mache einmal eine leckere nutella
creme zum bestreichen der torte und eine
dunkle gasse zum füllen und diese
benutze ich dann später eben auch für
die igel stacheln für den keller krink
verwende ich 100 gramm weiche butter 50
gramm frischkäse und 200 gramm nutella
für die zar peter kanal verwende ich 150
gramm sahne und 300 gramm zucker
schokolade für die zar peter schaar
schloss sich die sahne in einem topf
aufkochen dann ziehe ich sie wieder vom
herd herunter und höre jetzt die zahl
bitterschokolade ein und höre sie so
lange bis sie schön glatt ist bei der
kanadische ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass
sie jetzt um gefüllt und so abgedeckt
wird und dann darf sie bei
raumtemperatur stehen und zwar so lange
bis sie schön abgekühlt ist die könnte
zum beispiel auch am tag vorzubereiten
auf jeden fall nicht in den kühlschrank
stellen weil sie ansonsten zu festwirt
und ihr seht dann nicht mehr verrühren
könnt jetzt kann ich noch so nutella
creme machen
dafür nehme ich weiche butter die kommt
in eine rührschüssel und wird schön
geschmeidig verrührt
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt noch den frischkäse
dazu da werden die zutaten kurz
verbunden
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich einen ausstecher ihr
könnt natürlich auch im glas oder einen
teller nehmen außenrum schneiden und der
hat jetzt 14 zentimeter im durchmesser
und je nachdem wie groß der durchmesser
ist zu dick wird der egl hat auch also
je größer und da können natürlich selber
entscheiden wie groß er später werden
soll
jetzt wird der kuchen ausgestochen
[Musik]
es ist nämlich backpapier unter
weggezogen und jetzt nehmt ihr euch zum
beispiel an torten drehteller da kann
man super arbeiten einen toten retter
drauf kommentierte erste boden drauf und
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr das ganze
noch mit marmelade bestreichen
ich nehme jetzt einfach eine erdbeer
marmelade weil die offenbar im
kühlschrank und dazwischen arbeite ich
jetzt mit der dunklen danach bitter weil
die eben auch immer schön fest wird und
so wird jetzt die komplette torte
gestapelt also einfach wie so eine
zylinder jetzt hoch bauen
[Musik]
so stelle ich die torte jetzt erstmal in
den kühlschrank damit sehr fest werden
kann für etwa eine halbe stunde bis
stunde und danach geht es weiter und die
reste auf jeden fall aufbewahren nicht
aufessen noch nicht nämlich ein bisschen
war es von der note ella buttercreme das
kommt hier drauf ihr könnt auch damit
gerne die torte ihnen fünf und jetzt
nämlich einen kleineren ausstecher und
die kuchen reste und bau hier einfach
nur was drauf
[Musik]
so dass der kopf einfach schön rundlich
wird jetzt nehme ich einfach ein messer
und schneidet den igel in form also so
dass er einfach oben ein bisschen
rundlicher ist und nach unten ein
bisschen dünner wird
[Musik]
das habe ich die form schon ganz grob
und jetzt streiche ich die torte einmal
komplett mit der dunklen garage ein und
dann kommt sie in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
durch diese erste schicht werden nämlich
die krümel dollar gebunden und dann gebe
ich sie in den kühlschrank und dadurch
wird sie auch schön fest und ich kann
gut an hier weiterarbeiten
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt fest und jetzt gehts
am dekorieren
die cremes müssen jetzt von der
konsistenz sage streicht wie ich sein
also die dunkler danach stehe habe ich
eben kurzem schneebesen durch gerührt
die ist jetzt schön streichfähig ekel
wird jetzt einmal komplett mit der note
a la creme eingestrichen
[Musik]
jetzt zwischendurch noch einmal kühlen
und dann komplett glatt streichen wenn
ihr die torte perfekt glatt streichen
wollt dann könnt ihr zum beispiel einen
leeren joghurtbecher nehmen und hier den
rand wegschneiden
[Musik]
dann einmal aufschneiden und schön
gerade schneiden da reicht dann auch die
hälfte
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr das ganze nehmen unten
ansetzen und nach oben hin glatt ab zu
[Musik]
schon ist die trotte glatt und im
prinzip muss ja auch nur hier vorne
glatt sein
hinten kommt nämlich jetzt sowieso das
eagle muster aus weißer modelle
schokolade vor mich jetzt zum einen die
füße die hände und die schnauze und die
ohren fliegen
[Musik]
die bekommen jetzt eine stupsnase also
rolle ich jetzt hier die modelle
schokolade in der mitte so ein bisschen
auseinander also das sind damit einfach
diese stupsnase stehen bleibt das jetzt
noch mal gleich noch eine nase drauf
aber zumindest kann man so dass er sich
schon eingesellt formen hände füße und
ohren sind geformt jetzt das gesicht das
lege ich mir gleich dran um auch die
größe abzuschätzen
jetzt riecht aber erstmal in igls zu mir
ich habe übrigens hinten eine fläche die
ein bisschen gerade ist das ist der
rücken und vorne ist eben das gesicht
und der bau und jetzt kann ich mit einem
messer einfach auch schon mal die
grenzen markieren wurde staffeln gehen
sollen
[Musik]
dann kann ich jetzt hier die schnauze zu
schneiden
so ein bisschen was für die augen
[Musik]
die schnauze ist schön angeklebt und
jetzt sind die augen an der reihe dafür
habe ich einfach ein bisschen schwarze
modell schokolade bereits dünn
ausgerollt
jetzt nehme ich hier eine loch thüle ich
gucke natürlich auch das ist von der
größe her passt ein bisschen größer
hätte ich gerne die augen
[Musik]
dann ausstechen
und dann mit essbarem kleber ankleben
[Musik]
aus dem rest frau mich jetzt noch eine
kleine nase dann zwischen den fingern so
ein bisschen dreieckig formen und auch
vorne an die nase geben
[Musik]
hier drücke ich jetzt noch einen kleinen
mund ein
und hier am mundwinkel drücke ich jetzt
noch mit einem rollstuhl zu 20 1
[Musik]
dann nehme ich weiße zucker schrift und
machen die lichtpunkte in die augen
[Musik]
jetzt bekommt der idee noch wo sawani um
das bin ich immer ganz neu ist und dann
auch wieder mit etwas zucker kleber
einfach krank
ein bisschen rosen gesetzt und schon
sind die regel frecher auf
[Musik]
ich habe mit den süßen eagle auf eine
schieferplatte gesagt und ich habe ich
jetzt einen spritzbeutel mit einer
glashülle also vorne sind viele kleine
löcher drin
ihr könnt auch wenn ihr jetzt so was und
ich habe einfach eine stern teilnehmen
und damit der stern verlauf da kommt
jetzt die ghanaer schreien und bei der
garage ist es ganz wichtig dass der von
der konsistenz her streichfähig ist also
nicht so flüssig und nicht so fest so
wie hier und weiß halt wirklich wichtig
dass man über raumtemperatur lagert und
wenn sie doch ein bisschen zu weich ist
dann gibt sie ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank
aber da muss man immer daran denken dass
sie nach zieht also die wird danach noch
mal fester mit dem durchrühren deswegen
immer dabei bleiben
und jetzt markiere ich mir hier die
stelle an denen ich das edel fan ist es
nämlich die egl stacheln auch spritze
und dann am besten hinten anfangen und
vorsichtig spritzen
[Musik]
und ihr okay segeln
jetzt ist die torte fertigt und wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr jetzt noch mit dem crash
das modell der schokolade modelle
schokolade das ist eine modelliermasse
mit 25% echter schokolade und damit
können auch anfänger ganz gut arbeiten
weil sie nämlich mit der hand wärme
weich wird und einfach beim abkühlen
aushärtet man kann wirklich auch ganz
lange drum rum modellieren
ich nehme jetzt etwas grüne modelle
schokolade und knete sie was daraus
entsteht dann eine lange rolle und zwei
kleine rollen damit mache ich jetzt den
kaktus
jetzt nehme ich etwas rote modell
schokolade und gebt da gelbe
lebensmittelfarbe dazu damit sie leicht
auch aus wird die moderne schokolade
wird dann lang ausgerollt gerade
zugeschnitten
in die mitte form ich dann alle internen
kegel und legt dann das band strom herum
sodass ein blumentopf entsteht
alle teile müssen jetzt ganz kurz aus
herten und die füge ich jetzt mit etwas
essbarem kleber zusammen
und da unten kommen jetzt zuckerstraße
rein das ist dann die erde
[Musik]
und die seitenteile die befestige ich
auch mit zahnstocher und mit liebe muss
man natürlich vorher sagen falls doch
jemand den kaktus essen möchte da ist
ein zahnstocher dran
und dem lasso einfach fest werden was
ich euch auf jeden fall als tipp geben
kann gerade bei dem spritzbeutel ich
habe nochmal am zweiten darüber gesetzt
so ist ein bisschen stabiler weil
einfach viel druck ausgeübt wird und
hinten mit einem gummi verschlossen
wichtig ist nämlich dass ihr clinton den
vogue nicht hier vorne weil dann spritzt
die ganze krämer hinten raus hier hinten
die hand gedrückt und die führt und dann
immer kleine kurze bewegung und durch
die hand wärme wird die garage auch
immer schön weich und behält einfach die
perfekte konsistenz sorgt die brauche
ich jetzt erstmal nicht mehr dekanats
kann man übrigens auch ganz gut
einfrieren
jetzt stelle ich den edel im prinzip
fertig ich habe jetzt hier die füße da
schneide ich jetzt den vorderen teil weg
und setzt sie vorne dran und dann noch
die hände und die bauern
[Musik]
um in süßer kleiner neuer lebensfreude
er hat nur noch keinen namen er oder sie
nicht auf den namen dürft ihr euch
aussuchen und dann schreibt ihn einfach
in die kommentare und den schönsten und
coolsten namens nicht aus und schreiben
dann in den titel
und jetzt noch der kaktus so zu veredeln
kaktus ich habe eigentlich nichts
gemeinsam aber ein edles oder kaktus ist
es also passt ja doch ganz gut den stern
also dazu
[Musik]
ich finde die resultate richtig süß ich
habe irgendwie das bedürfnis den die
ganze zeit zu streichen aber das machen
wir lieber nichts was ist die cala
später kaputt
falls ihr möchtest dass ich mal andere
tiere so als toto mache dann schreibt
gerne in die kommentare
also eure wünsche welches tier würdet
ihr gerne als nächstes sehen und
vergesst nicht einen namens wunsch oder
eine namens idee und in die kommentare
zu schreiben
dann suche ich nämlich eine zwischen
damen aus der männchen oder weibchen das
weiß ich selber nicht das dürft ihr
entscheiden und der kunst der name der
kommt dann wie gesagt in den titel
das rezept gibst du nachlesen auf sallys
- blog.de ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachbacken verlinkt mich auf jeden
fall auf eurem fotos und die torte die
geht heute ins nicht dem video
angeschnitten die bekommt die iena
später und dann erst hinter sich
zusammen mit einer unter mir also bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]